everybody here was of course ignored and
brushed aside or chiefly polite reasons
Terry wants to know where the money's
coming from and yes you got to put money
in we've got a set money being wasted
I mentioned health terrorism okay here's
a fact and I'm sure that other people
will be mortified that I dare to talk
about it there are 7,000 diagnoses in
this country every year for people who
are HIV positive which not a good place
for any of them to be I know
but 60% of them are not British
nationals you can come into Britain from
anywhere in the world and get diagnosed
with HIV and get the retroviral drugs
that cost up to 25,000 pounds per year
per patient I know there are some
horrible things happening in many parts
of the world what we need to do is to
put the National Health Service there
for British people and families who in
many cases are paid into this system for
decades Thank You Liam would this kind
of scam endure in anger in practice is
dangerous it dangerous it divides
communities and it creates stigma to
people who are ill and I think you go
Joe you're shamed of yourself well I'm
sorry we've got to put our own people
for watching would you Leah would you
Leanne open it up to 17,000 27,000
people don't the question is how do we
fund the NHS and if two billion pounds a
year is being lost on health tourism
surely that is 18 today you know
Nicholas Stern when some day is
diagnosed with the dreadful illness my
instinct is to view them as a human
being not consider what country they
come from in fact I want to go back to
something ed Miliband said earlier and
he said there should be limits on the
privatization of the National Health
Service
I'm sorry as I take a very definite view
there should be no privatization of the
health services our National Health
Service is far too precious to give up
for private profit and to let Cley you
legislate Otello 49% of hospital beds to
be used with the private sector say
write my message to people in England
Wales and Northern Ireland if there are
SNP MPs in the House of Commons after
the election and you want to roll back
the tide of privatisation we will be
your ally